-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian,
actor and author,
you can see him on the road
touring around the country.
For ticket information
go to colinquinn.com.
Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Colin Quinn everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
You are one of our modern
historians
-Whoa!
-...of this great city.
-Yes.
-You know a lot
about New York City.
And you have a great new...
-You're coming in hot,
by the way.
-I'm coming in hot.
I want to big you up.
-You've been on already.
You've been on already.
I just got out here.
[ Laughter ]
And by the way,
before we start
not to break the momentum,
I don't like this.
-Okay.
-The old days of a nice cup.
-Yeah.
-Look at this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sorry.
-Jesus.
-You really?
-Because it makes me
look cheap now
that I'm drinking it.
[ Laughter ]
The crowd doesn't know.
They'll be like,
Look at that chiseler.
People on TV,
it's all about perception.
You know what I mean,
folks?
[ Laughter ]
I like to work the crowd.
Work in comedy is big now.
So I try to work
the crowd on TV.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-That should be --
That should be your new
catchphrase as a comedian.
It isn't like
an actual catchphrase,
but after your punch lines,
you take a sip
from a tiny thing of water.
[ Laughter ]
It gave them the exact right
amount of time to laugh.
-Yeah.
-It might look a little
creepy, but you're right.
-Just tiny sips.
-Yeah.
And the whole thing
is, he makes it --
You know,
he makes it last the whole hour.
[ Laughter ]
Tiny little sips.
You have a --
I was -- I was setting you up.
Yes, I know.
I know.
You were talk--
You have
this new show called --
-And you're like, "Hey."
-Hey.
Look, you want
to talk about
"Block by Block,"
no problem.
You have a YouTube
show called "Block by Block"
where you're going
to different neighborhoods
in New York City.
-Yeah.
-And you're talking
about the history.
What makes them unique.
-Yes.
You've done Yorkville.
You've done Hell's Kitchen.
-Yeah.
When you were growing up
in New York,
did different neighborhoods
have different reputations
that were interesting to you?
-Oh, sure.
But you can't discuss those now.
They're all based on ethnicity.
-Okay, gotcha. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So now you just are like,
"Oh, that --
Oh, I know that one.
That's northeast of here.
-You're like,
Oh, that block, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You have to get
very vague.
But, um, yeah.
But these guys, you know,
these people
from back in the day.
So my friend Steve Kelly
in Yorkville
and he goes over the history,
but also the brawls --
the giant fights
they'd have at
the Second Avenue bars.
He left his comic strip post
to go across the street,
got in a big brawl.
The cops are everywhere.
And he goes back
to the comic strip
where, ironically,
he's in charge of security.
And then my friend Mike Spillane
was was telling the story
about him
and his brother and his cousin
and a couple of other guys.
And they get in a fight
in a bar, a couple of guys,
but then he realize
one of the guy's friends
they're fighting
is Andre the Giant.
[ Laughter ]
So he picks him up
and just flings him.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like you should get
a visual
on Andre the Giant
before the fight starts.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
No, actually,
he did see him
in the bathroom
and he goes, "Oh, wow."
But he didn't know he
was with the guy...
-Oh, that's the problem.
-...boys were about the fight.
-I think just out of safety,
if Andre the Giant was there,
I wouldn't start any fights.
You never know
who's his plus one.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Andre the Giant
with a plus one. I like that.
[ Laughter ]
-And did you -- What were, like,
what were sort of like --
What about Flushing?
What was the reputation
about Flushing.
-Flushing, back then
it was kind of Irish, Italian,
Jewish, like a lot of names,
and now, it's all Asian.
And then it became Korean
and then it became Chinese.
So even the Koreans
now have left Flushing.
They moved to Bayside.
-So it's just like it
just rotates through.
You just have like one
after the other,
a different identity comes
through.
-Yeah.
-That's fascinating.
-I agree.
-You talked about small talk
and how it's a lost art,
but I was wondering,
small talk
in different countries,
you travel a lot,
do you find like
certain cultures
are better at small talk?
-Well, I mean Irish.
It depends what you like
for small talk,
if you like being -- having,
you know, your balls busted,
The Irish people.
-Yeah.
-You know.
They like that banter.
-Yeah.
-Is what I mean.
You know what I mean?
So I was in Ireland,
like we went,
we went last summer
to Ireland.
So I go to the -- There's
a girl behind this, like,
podium at the hotel restaurant.
So I'm the guy that likes to,
you know,
like, I like to play around
with all the people,
Like I'm the guy in my building
if somebody's mopping,
every time
I walk in the lobby,
I pretend to slip like,
"Hey!" and pretend.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not the Mark Twain
humor prize,
but, you know, that's...
That's my thing.
I like to be like,
"Hey!"
Have a couple
of laughs and move on.
Nobody gets hurt.
We'll, have a nice laugh.
And, um...
I'm getting mad thinking about
people judging.
And...
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Oh, yeah,
it's funny."
You know, I'm not --
I'm not a prideful guy, but --
-Everybody thinks it's funny
that you do that.
I'm sure the guy
mopping must love it.
-He loves it.
-Yeah.
-Every time.
-Yeah, yeah.
And sometimes, like,
if it's the same guy,
then I'll wait
the extra second
because, you know, surprise
is the element in comedy.
[ Laughter ]
And then he's like,
"Oh, he's not going to do it."
And I pass him,
then I do it anyway.
[ Laughter ]
But anyway.
-Ireland.
-Audience will want --
Oh, so I go to Ireland.
So there's a girl
behind the counter
at the podium at this
restaurant in the hotel,
and she's quiet, like 19.
But Irish people,
they all have the same
ballbuster sense of humor.
So I go, "I want the best table
in here," you know?
And she goes --
She doesn't know me --
She goes,
"You deserve no less."
[ Laughter ]
And I go,
"My wife is joining me."
She goes,
"She's a lucky woman."
[ Laughter ]
I love it.
-You -- you
traveled to Greece.
You were in Greece this summer.
-I was in Greece
this summer.
-What is your takeaway?
-Epiphany.
I don't think there's --
Maybe that's a Greek word.
-I think it is.
-Epiphany.
Well, because they go,
"Do you want to see
the birthplace of democracy
where it all began?"
And I go, "Yeah."
It's rubble. It's ruins.
[ Laughter ]
So that's what
we're headed for.
We -- Democracy
worked for like 150 years.
And then it was monarchy,
a great system
for thousands of years.
And then we decided to unearth
this failed rubble system.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-[ Laughs ]
-We had the perfect
setup in 1775,
a remote king.
That's the best
form of government.
-Yeah.
-He didn't know
what we're doing.
We did whatever
we wanted over here.
-Yeah.
-You know?
But he couldn't -- It'd take
him 40 days to get over here.
But we could use his name.
We'd use his name.
If Spain
and Portugal step to us,
we're like, "King George
might not like that."
We gave it all away
for stamps and tea.
[ Laughter ]
When's the last time
anyone used...?
It's e-mail
and coffee over here.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
-You feel like humor
has changed from --
from when you were growing up,
like the tenor of humor?
Well, when we
were little kids,
I mean, I remember
as a little kid,
that's why when people say
you got to make everybody laugh,
you don't have to make
young kids laugh.
I don't want to make
I don't have the same sense
of you because I know how dumb
what I thought was funny
when I was young.
I remember some kid was like,
"Hey, that guy's a real master."
And he goes, "bater!"
And I was like, at the time.
I go, That's pretty.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, yeah.
He put...
[ Laughter ]
That he put them
together like that.
I'll give you a test.
Seth spell "I-cup."
-I C-U-P.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Drum roll ]
-That's the kind of stuff.
-Yeah, So you're saying that --
-We get when going back.
-In those days,
-You're not judging them
for enjoying that,
but you don't want to --
You don't want
to cater to that audience?
-No, exactly.
-And do you feel like comedy
has become more negative
than when you were a kid?
-Well, not just comedy.
Everything's more negative.
I was watching.
Look at Taylor Swift.
She goes out.
[ Audience cheers ]
Right?
She goes to the game.
Like in the old days,
you're like,
"Oh, look, an athlete
and a singer going out.
This is great."
Everybody's like, "Oh!"
You know, we don't even
know why everybody's upset,
But they're like,
I don't like it.
We're all waiting for the whole
thing to crash and burn.
-Yeah.
Every game you're like,
"Look at her in the stands
with the mother."
It's the most whole--
-[ Laughs ]
-it's the most wholesome thing
I've ever seen in my life.
-I'm also shocked that
sports fans are upset
that there's not
more focus on football.
There's so little football
in a football game,
and it's just those
two guys in a booth.
They're trying
to make small talk.
They're trying to make --
-Yes!
-They got nothing to say.
-That's right.
-I think it's such
a great relief
just to cut to people
who seem happy.
-They must love it.
Yes, they must love it.
-Yeah.
-As a Jets fan, were you --
How do you feel
about the season so far?
-Well, we're excited because,
first of all,
people don't understand.
I've been a Jets fan
since I was a little kid.
The Jets, I was there
when they, well, not there,
but I was watching or listening.
I forget how it
was in those days.
But when the Jets,
when Joe Namath was there,
and I remember thinking
even as a 10-year-old kid
like, "This makes sense."
It's New York,
it's a big market.
It'll probably be
like this forever, right?
Little did I know.
But when Aaron Rodgers
got the Achilles,
the first set of downs,
any real Jets fan was not like,
"I can't believe it."
Of course.
What else would you
expect to happen?
Right.
[ Laughter ]
-So you weren't
that surprised?
-No, I wasn't at all.
I mean, it made perfect sense.
-We're fellow writers.
Writer strike's over.
That's a good thing.
You, um, you have
a negotiating tactic,
because I know a lot
of people were --
had their notes about like,
"Oh, if I was on
the negotiating committee,
I would have say this or that."
But you -- you take care
of your own contract.
-Two months before
the writer's strike,
I happen to be telling my wife,
who, you know,
deals with that kind of stuff,
I go when I --
All my career,
a little fun secret fact
I thought about me,
I go all my whole career
whenever they hand me
the contract,
this started in the '80s,
and it says in perpetuity
in all forms existing
and in the future.
Back in the '80s,
this one is one of
the big contract points,
but I always cross it off
in every contract
anyone ever handed me,
if it was on the show.
Anyway, I cross it off
with my pen.
So I told her that
and she literally spent
a minute laughing in my face.
[ Laughter ]
-So in perpetuity, you were
just never comfortable
with people
owning it forever.
-Yeah, in all forms,
existing and in the future.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-So what would you -- what
would you negotiate instead?
100 years?
Well, just --
I don't like these...
Well, who knew?
This is before any --
This is before the streaming,
Anything like that.
You know, AI.
I was ahead of the game
is what I'm trying to say.
-Yeah.
And she laughs at you.
You're ahead of the game.
-She laughed at me.
-A futurist like yourself?
-Yeah, exactly.
-[ Laughs ]
-Exactly.
-One final thing.
You know, obviously you interact
with showbiz people.
There's a lot of showbiz
small talk.
Sometimes people will say,
"We should get together
sometime."
-Yeah.
Are you the kind of person
who likes to make plans
like that?
-Well, I don't.
I hate it.
but I always say,
"Yes, absolutely."
-Okay.
So that would be your advice.
-Never show up.
And then some people
actually have the nerve to,
like, call you on like,
"Hey, I thought we're getting
together for lunch."
I was like, "Um,
what are you talking about?"
[ Laughter ]
Did you seriously believe
we were going to get
together for lunch?
[ Laughter ]
So weird to me,
you know,
-So -- Right.
So it seems you --
It's just like words.
Like if someone's like,
"We should get together."
And you're like,
"Yeah, absolutely."
That's just like a pleasant way
of ending a conversation.
-Well, if I say it,
then I'm insulted
if they don't want to do it.
-Sure, sure.
That's a totally different --
-That's a different dynamic.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
It's always a pleasure
to talk to you,
Colin Quinn.
For ticket information
go to colinquinn.com.